voilà une fleur que j'adore leur guide
et je préfère l'observer dans la nature
mais en période de confinement je vous
en présente une qui vit en intérieur
toutes possèdent la même fleurs très
caractéristique
elle est constituée de six pièces floral
trois sépales 1 2 3 et trois pétales
qu'on a du mal à distinguer des
précédents 1,2 et le troisième
caractéristique des orchidées le label
souvent il sert de piste d'atterrissage
pour les insectes qui viennent butiner
lafleur car les organes sexuels les
étamines qui contiennent le pollen et le
pistil sont confinés tout au fond
parfois ce label reproduit la
morphologie d'un insecte femelles ce qui
attire davantage les mâles et favorise
la pollinisation bon celui ci est un
hybride pour sa reproduction
il va falloir la main de l'homme mais
bon ça fait quand même une jolie
capsules de déconfit aller à demain et
n'oubliez pas nous sommes toujours
confiné mais on reste en lien si vous
avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
vous pouvez aussi voir ou revoir celle
des jours précédents en cliquant sur le
côté gauche
et pour être sûr de ne rater aucune et
bien abonnez vous et activer la petite
cloche à très bientôt et n'oubliez pas
nous sommes confinés
mais en restant lien